police are searching for the suspect in  a hit-and-run crash that left a teenager  dead thank you for joining us tonight at  five o'clock i'm sasha loftis this  happened near durango and warm springs  on friday night the family has  identified the boy as 15-year-old keith  young jr a sophomore at sierra vista  high school his mother says he was  walking to a football game with his  younger brother on friday metro police  say that's when keith was hit by a car  the car was going so fast and  didn't even tap his brakes after it  happened he just kept going  police are now looking for a red dodge  charger with a missing left mirror and  possible windshield damage if you know  anything contact police or crime crime  stoppers to remain anonymous